tu lo sai breve dobbiamo ac saluto che
vuole salire guarda dobbiamo svegliarci
che cioè non ha idea siamo in mega
ritardo sì è vero ma sveglia lo curto
sveglia lo devi alzarti andiamo hai
fatto la valigia ma manco io non ce la
facciamo
mettiamo il turbo cervello la dobbiamo
andare alla vecchia da tre ore perché
c'è l'ansia di perdere i treni queste
pronti manchino ancora valigia dovremmo
farlo dobbiamo anche trasferire tutta la
postazione tweet è sì cuore ma noi
abbiamo perso il treno da charlie wi fi
una cortesia a bahia sveglia pure male
che è quella più lento di noi a
prepararsi così riusciamo parte di tutti
quanti e non perdere strano come ci si
sente ad essere in ritardissimo per
andare a milano per una grande
produzione e troveremo anche da milano
ma guarda non so se riusciremo a
portarci a casa log off perché il treno
sarebbe buono e in effetti vogliamo
ancora dorme svegliati alla fine ci sono
tentato una lama da svegliare a disco
questo e pato io bayern ma scusa lui
viene con noi infatti soffre un po ma
lavora come sto cercando di sfuggire
mico scappare via ma pubblicità
progresso giovane al momento di privacy
sono un hub cioè ignorandomi della mia
bbb bbb fiat e questo giovane tentando
queste sono le domande che se con le
biciclette per esempio no che il look
famiglie cosiddette un vero artista
concettuale come te
i biglietti l'ha disegnata male cazzo
tratti questo papa valigia mojave io non
la mia non sempre questo comportamento
di prima mattina non voglio essere
disturbato ma tramite fai tutto in
questa famiglia scorsa amico eredi
guarda è un'illusione ottica questa da
paul ancora certa tener a mente
dell'artista vado e bloccando perché mi
pare il trattenimento per questo diciamo
una di quelle campione meravigliose come
quelle che ci ha riservato nella mente è
consentito di ragazzi veloci per fare
una ripresa però cinematografica porta a
porta
siamo dirlo più traumatico pianse ancora
non è partito io sono svegliata 70 voli
avrei potuto assemblarlo vuoi metterlo
su tagli e partire verso milano non
arrivò nemmeno 19 ma a quanto pare
natale del caso della canzone di marco
cricca siamo partiti per stare sulla
linea io sono affezionata dai
caricabatterie è preso molte scarto
enrico quale ciao valentina a sorpresa
siamo rimasti gli altri sono da via
milano e capri
oddio non ho visto sinceramente dopo che
mi hai buttato l'acqua addosso questo
potrebbe essere un giorno speciale bay
arena
ma se ti può consolare la dimenticatemi
occhiato a darti sto mangiando il punto
gli immigrati che c'è non ci credo ma
non l'abbiamo già comprato quel che
vogliamo fare uno scherzetto enrico
risalire sul treno rate riparte ma non
tornano al posto e farti credere è
atterrato all'aereoporto
ma secondo me li non se ne renderà conto
andiamo a sederci da qualche parte
trenta e passa anni e non sentirli
[Musica]
andate a cagare
abbiamo simpatici da quando è passato
non vi ho visto io non vi ho visto il
panico no io non sapevo che fare tutta
sta roba che allora circuito quello
quell'altro fa proprio l'inventario vale
solo pensando che avere una giornata
speciale giorni prima di tutto alla casa
poi a quel punto siamo meritato un po di
riposo alla prima ti faccio un tan tetto
di cucina un po di pollo ai ferri
insalata verde così non già passato per
una volta facciamo delle belle maschere
facciali e poi che cosa ci possiamo
vedere tipo sismi mail la cosa mi dai
una serie ci sono già quattro stagioni e
filipe piano sempre voluto vedere
feedback ci intendiamo quelle otto
giorni dai così poi abbiamo praticamente
finito la giornata quindi pulizie pollo
con in sala pretty woman maschere e poi
fidc abbiamo avuto già mi da giorni e
anche l'ultimo stolto è andato ora la
casa
la mia scelta dice ancora dall'inizio al
blog
ok numero 16 facciamo vedere che cosa è
successo prima d ora tutto il video
[Musica]
beh
cadrebbe l'immagine che abbiamo qui
nelle scale mobili e molto mie scherino
appunto il covent mascherina
ho già un pazzo si sta facendo
concorrenti credo che anche quella carta
da parati del livello perché la nostra
commenta non è che risulta meglio una
vostra carta di vara in video
no loro sbatte posso dire ragazzi che
siete bravissimi staccando di fatica
come un tempo determinare vi ho avuta
colletta per niente perché penso che la
cosa migliore sposate tutto quanto sul
letto abbiamo più spazio così arretu
torni sulla lavoro posso dire che non sa
tutti i dati in arrivo di bhatti era poi
tanto i letti su due ma anche ne dite se
spostassimo la postazione trichet il
corridoio dovrebbe dormì sul tavolo
borello quando all'armadio guardato
espansione di chi poi entrano dentro in
vacca dentro la doccia di dormire con
wow che soluzione pratica by gruppo re
berlato letto la postazione quasi una
cagnara mamma ti saluto mi manchi
dobbiamo soltanto collegare questa
camera al a questo caso ci tengo a dire
una cosa ogni armellin costare abbiamo
giocato among us e mi ha fregato sul
finale dicendo fratello non potrei mai
fatti del male io non avevo mai giocato
da un gas non lo capisco ancora del
tutto questo prima partita è
ricominciata lucidato anche iniziato il
gioco perché era lui l'impostore e
allora la seconda ero io l'impostore
raga leonardo di caprio spostati
non capisco non capiva male
rubavano dentello realtà mi ha scatenato
come ultimo siamo rimasti io e lui l'ha
detto proprio il tipo aladin ti fidi di
me realtà mi ha fatto cascare dal
partito cuore era già fa che morisse
deve andare così ci vediamo domani
enrico chissà magari domani sarò lo
imposto e con un sorriso e con una pacca
ti aprirò la schiena domani alle 14 su
youtube